What I want to do
in this video is
think about how supply and/or
demand might change based
on changes in some
factors in the market.
And then think about what that
might do to the equilibrium
price and equilibrium quantity.
So let's say at
some period, this
is what the supply
curve looks like
and this is what the
demand curve looks like.
And then all of a sudden,
this thing happens.
A new disease-resistant
apple is invented.
What's likely to happen
for the next period?
Well, a new disease-resistant
apple being invented,
this is something that
clearly impacts the growers,
clearly impacts the suppliers.
All of a sudden, they'll
have fewer apples
succumbing to disease.
And so they will be able
to produce more apples.
So at any given
price point, this
will shift the
quantity supplied up.
So at any given
price point, it will
shift the quantity of
apples supplied up.
Or you could say that
the entire supply
curve is shifted to the
right, or supply goes up.
And let me draw
the entire curve.
And obviously, if now we have
disease-resistant apples,
even our minimum price to start
producing apples is lower.
Now, when we had the supply
curve shift in this way,
when it shifted
to the right, what
happens to the
equilibrium price?
Well our old equilibrium
price was right over here.
Our new equilibrium price--
so this is the old one.
And this is our new
equilibrium price.
We're assuming that demand
has not changed at all.
So this is our new
equilibrium price.
So our new equilibrium
price is lower.
So the price went down.
And you don't have to-- you
could have probably reasoned
through that before,
taking an econ class.
But this way, at least you
have some way to think about it
and think about how the
curves are changing.
Now, let's think
about this scenario.
So this is before.
So in all of these
examples, the graph
is what happened before
the news came out,
or the event came out.
So this is before.
And then a study is released
on how apples prevent cancer.
So what is that likely to do?
Well, no one wants cancer.
And so more people are going
to be eager to have apples.
This will change
customer preferences.
They will prefer
apples even more
when they're at the supermarket.
So this is clearly affecting
demand customer preferences.
And so at a given
price, people will
want-- they will demand a
higher quantity of apples.
The quantity of apples demanded
at a given price will go up.
So the demand curve
will shift to the right.
Or you could say, the
demand would go up.
So that's the new demand curve.
So here, demand goes up.
And let me write it over here.
In this situation,
supply went up.
Here, demand goes up.
And what happens to the price?
Well, this is our old
equilibrium price.
This is our new
The price clearly went up.
So the price went up.
And actually over here, let's
think about the quantity too
in this first situation.
This is our old
equilibrium quantity.
This is our new
Quantity went up,
which makes sense.
You have fewer apples
dying, price went down,
more people want to buy them.
Here, price went up, and
what happened to quantity?
Quantity-- this was our
old equilibrium quantity.
This is our new
equilibrium quantity.
Quantity also went up.
More people just
want to buy apples.
They don't want to get cancer.
Now let's think about these
scenarios right over here.
The pear cider industry
launches an ad campaign.
And for the sake of
this, let's assume
that the same growers who grow
apples can also grow pears.
That makes it interesting.
So you have a couple
of interesting things.
By launching this
advertising campaign--
we're going to assume
it's a good advertising
campaign-- this clearly will
make demand go up for-- sorry,
it'll make demand go up
for cider, for pear cider,
relative to apple cider.
Most people, when
they think of cider,
they think of apple cider.
Now all of a sudden,
pear cider comes out.
It'll make demand for
apple cider go down.
So this is apple cider
demand will go down.
Now, if apple cider
demand goes down,
the apple cider producers are
going to demand fewer apples.
So this is going to mean that
apple demand will go down.
At any given price point,
So apple demand, the demand
curve, will shift to the left.
Or I should say at
any given price point,
the quantity demanded
will go down.
And so the entire demand
curve, the entire relationship,
will shift to the left.
Now, that's not all
that might happen.
Because if you think about
it from the suppliers
point of view, and I don't know
if this really is the case,
but let's assume that the
farmers who grow apples
can also grow pears.
Well, they might say,
well, now that there's
more demand for pears,
they're doing this advertising
campaign, I want to-- and
probably the price of pears
has gone up-- they
might say, well,
I'm going to devote more of
my land to pears and less
of my land to apples.
And so the supply of apples-- so
apple supply-- want to be clear
here that we're talking about
apple-- the apple supply
might go down.
So it'll also shift to the left.
So they're both
shifting to the left.
Now what is likely
to happen here?
So the demand went down
and the supply went down.
They both shifted to the left.
Well, here the way I drew it,
this was our old equilibrium
price, this is our
new equilibrium price.
It actually looks the way that
I drew it right over here,
that it did not change.
The equilibrium quantity
definitely did change.
So let's see, this is our
old equilibrium quantity.
This is our new
equilibrium quantity.
This clearly, the
quantity, went down.
It was a bad day for apples.
But the price didn't
change, because, at least
in the example, we assume
that the farmers actually also
produced fewer apples.
It turns out, I could have
drawn this in multiple ways.
And actually, let me draw
it in different ways here.
So the quantity
definitely-- so let's
think about other scenarios.
Let me draw it
slightly different.
Let's say that the supply goes
down even more dramatically.
So let's say the supply shifts
all the way-- the supply shifts
really far back.
Now, what happened?
Well now, our
equilibrium price--
because the reduction in
supply was kind of more extreme
than the reduction in demand.
And it really depends on how the
curve shapes and all of that.
The main thing is
to reason through it
or to actually see what
the actual results are.
But in this situation, all of a
sudden that the price went up,
but the quantity
definitely still went down.
So in this case, the one
thing that you're always
going to be sure of
is that the quantity
will go down but
the price went up.
Because this effect-- the
supply went down much more
than the demand did.
And so the price went up.
Now I could have done
another scenario.
I could have done another
scenario where maybe the supply
barely budged or maybe the
demand went down dramatically.
Let me draw it where the
supply barely budges.
So maybe the supply, it only
gets shifted a little bit
to the left.
So maybe the supply
curve looks like this.
Now all of a sudden, once again,
quantity definitely goes down.
So in all of the scenarios,
the quantity will go down.
But I've just done three
scenarios where the price could
be neutral, the price could go
up, or the price could go down.
So you actually
don't know what is
going to happen to the
price based on this.
You would actually have to
look at the actual curve
and see what the new
equilibrium prices are.
Now let's look at this one.
The apple pickers unionize and
they demand wage increases.
So this is an issue
for the suppliers.
So all of a sudden,
one of their inputs,
one of their costs of
production, which is labor,
has gone up.
So if their cost of
production has gone up,
now at a given price point,
they are less profitable,
less willing to produce apples.
So at a given price
point-- so we're
talking about the suppliers--
at a given price point,
they will supply
a lower quantity.
So this is going
to lower supply.
And when you lower supply,
what's going to happen?
Well, your
equilibrium quantity--
this was our old one, this
was our new one-- equilibrium
quantity definitely goes
down, the quantity went down.
And what happened to the price?
We're assuming nothing
changes to the demand.
So this was our old
equilibrium price.
This is our new
It went up.
Quantity went down,
and price went up.
And I encourage
you to-- well one,
I should have told you
this at the beginning, too.
You should have tried to do
these yourself and then see
what I had to say
about them-- but I
encourage you to try this out
with different situations.
Think of situations
yourself and even
think about different markets
other than the apple market.